we're learning more about the upcoming
royal wedding Prince Harry and his
American fiance Megan Marco will be
married in May and st. George's Chapel
at Windsor Castle before then she'll
apply for British citizenship and she'll
be baptized into the Church of England
Charlie d'Agata is outside Windsor
Castle that's just west of London
charlie good morning good morning we
found out that Harry and Megan have been
coming here since they started dating
this romantic little getaway outside of
London it's also one of the Queen's
favorite properties holding the wedding
here just made sense they're going to
this chapel where they're going to get
married five hundred year old st.
George's Chapel set in the sprawling
grounds of Windsor Castle but it's kind
of like the private family church it's
where Harry was baptized where his
father Charles and stepmother Camila
held their blessing ceremony after a
civil marriage in 2005 the palace has
agreed to foot the bill for pretty much
everything the church service music
flowers and the decorations even the
reception and Markel has already spent
time with the woman who signs the checks
the Queen it's incredible I think you
know a to be able to meet her through
his lens not just with his honor and
respect for her as the monarch but the
love that he has for her as his
grandmother but while most brides marry
into the family Markel is marrying into
a country and for a prince to marry a
divorcee reflects the evolving attitudes
towards divorce in the royal family
after all the Queen wouldn't be queen if
her uncle King Edward the eighth hadn't
abdicated the throne in 1936 to marry
another American divorcee Wallis Simpson
royal correspondent Roy Anika our next
king and queen are both divorced Charles
was able to divorce his first wife and
marry his second wife who is also
divorced he has not had to give up his
claim to the throne divorce simply is
not the tubu it was in the royal family
40 50 60 years ago now the guest list I
can tell you one person who will be
there that's a person who set Harry and
Megan up on that blind date she has yet
to be identified he could be certain
he'll be here
Nora Charlie d'Agata outside Windsor
Castle thank you that's right and I've
been wondering who she is
I know who she is I remember and it
wasn't it reported that um that her
friends that sort of just wanted to know
was he nice yes and that a great
question even just there's everything
about this story that just makes you
feel good and don't we need some good
news today yeah I don't see a wedding
inside st. George's like mm-hmm
liked it very much